European Union agricultural ministers  met in Brussels to discuss market  developments especially the impact of  Russia's ban on imports of certain fresh  produce from the EU in August Russia  announced a 12 month ban on perishable  fruit and vegetables meat fish and dairy  products after the EU imposed sanctions  on Moscow over the conflict in eastern  Ukraine emergency measures have been put  in place for fruit vegetables and dairy  products to alleviate impact of the ban  however Minister showed some concern on  the efficiency of those measures on a  long-term basis and on the impact of the  ban in particular